so we got to share with the employees
because without employees we can't make
a profit and if employees make more
money they have more purchasing power
the economy functions better but we must
open up we must it's it's so crucial
that small Enterprise that we don't TI
them up in Chains and with
[Music]
regulations
hello everyone watching and listening
today I have the honor to speak with
Frank stac founder and CEO of Magna
International one of Canada and the
world's great companies um Frank built
that company from nothing starting in
the 1950s it's quite a story we
discussed the keys to motivating
yourself to starting and maintaining a
successful and expanding business why
that's a good thing for yourself and
everybody else the idea contained within
within his corporate Constitution it's
an economic Charter of Rights which
advocates for the input autonomy and
profit sharing uh among all all workers
management um shareholders Etc and I'm
very much looking forward to talking
about it with him hello Mr struk it's
very very nice to see you um we met a
couple of months ago at a restaurant in
in Toronto and I had the opportunity to
talk to you about your business ventures
over the last five or six decades um
which I found extraordinarily
interesting in in the intervening period
of time I've read your I've read one of
your books uh the one that's more
autobiographical um and um I'm very
interested in your story I thought you
would make a particularly good podcast
guest because one of the things I do
with my pod
is walk people through the lives of
successful individuals
because I think it would be better if
people believed that they could move
forward successfully in the world and
that they were equipped with some
knowledge about how to do that and I
think that's something we could really
concentrate on focusing in on I know
it's very important to you in this
podcast you came to Canada in the 19 50s
we'll we'll go through your story
autobiographically you came armed with a
tiny bit of money some actual
skill some determination and out of that
you built a massive business Empire
let's start let's start with this not
everyone listening and watching are are
going to know what Magna Enterprises is
so would you do us the favor first of
laying out your business Empire tell
people what it is that you do and what
you've accomplished how you spread out
through the world what you guys
manufacture just lay out the story The
the description of Magna okay I've
always said life is a question of fate
and circumstances being at the right
places at the right time with the right
ingrediences as it happened uh I was
born in a workingclass family and when I
finished my schooling and I had one or
two years practical experience I wanted
to see the world I applied for a visa to
South Africa Australia the United States
and Canada sometimes I'm a little tough
on the Canadian bureaucracy but I'm
saying it's still the best because they
came first forward with a Visa so I
landed in queek city I took the cheapest
fair I could you know from Holland on a
cold freighter and uh uh so I arrived in
qu back in I think was about April uh
1954 and uh the immigration officer
asked me do you know anybody in Canada I
said no so I said well then you go to
Montreal so I moved to so I took a train
to Montreal uh uh and but I didn't know
anybody my English was reasonably okay
and I there were some uh
English-speaking people on that ship and
so I tried to practice my English so
anyway I knew because I had to $100 in
my pocket and I knew that wouldn't last
me too long if it would if I would right
away uh uh b a hotel or whatever it's so
uh so the people told me look just walk
along the streets and it's customary if
you see a sign room to let just knock on
the door and then you might get a room
so I did work for an hour or two right I
I knocked on but there were a few signs
I've seen I knocked on the door I think
I kind of looked a little rough from uh
the long uh journey and uh so they say
it's already leased but I did find one I
did find the room so the next morning I
got up and uh and uh I looked at the
road maps and looked at and walked
around and I worked in the factory but
it was in 54 there was a a major
recession I just couldn't find the job
right
and um during that time I was hungry
hungry enough because I wanted to lose
weight I was hungry I had no money to
buy food and if you experienced that
that's a that's a an impression which
will last forever it's burnt in your
soul right so anyway I run out of money
I was hungry I I had an acquaintance not
a close friend but somebody know from
the same down they came from and uh that
was in kitchen right so I saved enough
Monies to do I bought a gry home buset
and uh and I moved to Kitchen I traveled
by bu by kitchen from Montreal and uh so
when I got off after the main Square I
asked somebody what such and such
address is they said look go up there
four blocks and then ask again so up
four blocks ask well uh go up to three
more blocks and then you might have to
make it left and so I again I I after
about two hours of walking I could find
the house where that fell uh lived and I
knocked on the door and an elderly lady
said uh Max that was the fellow's name
there somebody want to see me I was very
uh it was a very happy feeling you know
to meet somebody uh which you know from
previous days so anyway Max came down
and he looked at me he said you kind you
look a little rough are you hungry I
said yes come on in so uh the next day I
slept there the next day we started chop
hunting uh uh in in the industrial site
there was nothing but I did find a jop
at the kitchen of waterl Hospital in the
kitchen and uh so I I felt so sorry for
myself I feel when I come to Canada I
got a manly job know cutting trees down
or taking out Stones something manly but
I was there and the catching with a lot
of elderly women nothing against elderly
women my mother was an elderly woman I
liked her but I felt sorry for myself to
peeling potatoes washing salads etc etc
so the evening I was just itching to get
away to me amongst people in those days
there were there was an aan clopping
kitchen so I went there and those days
they were slow dancing right a lot of
music and when they danced with the girl
you know uh you know what you do where
you from I say I'm from Austria what you
do well I work in the hospital my hands
were so smooth from washing dishes they
thought I was a surgeon so but that was
the end they always kind of said no I'm
just working in the kitchen then I did I
guess they didn't want to dance Clos
they didn't want to go out with the guy
which works in the kitchen but that's
the way life is but anyway after a
little while uh I after a about of
months or so I did found a job in an
engineering and a production oriented
company they uh that company worked
exclusive exclusively for the Arro a
aircraft right which um uh which uh
Canada developed and uh and but that um
that project
was wasn't financed anymore and it was
it it it was close the factory the AO
aircraft Factory I think was closed the
company I worked for was closed so
I I had checked a right to from Kitchen
to to Oak Fort was building a a new
Factory at the time there there were
huge lineups I waited about for about 2
three hours before they interviewed me
and interviewed Lo uh um yes you're d d
you're too young to get have any
experiences so I wasn't hired and I
drifted to uh to Toronto down had right
to Toronto but um years later I had uh
had U many times uh you know meeting a
lunch meeting din meeting with the
president of Ford and I told me you're
lucky if I got H at the time I would be
the President right so I I could tease
him right I knew well enough that I
could but any I did find a job there in
a very small company you know about 10
people after a year after a few months
uh the guy said the own said you're
doing a great job I want you to be a
partner of mine and uh and my chest
swelled a little and that's great and uh
nice guy but he'd never wrote it down
what it's all
about so I I said to myself there's
nothing to do with to run the factory so
I looked in the paper
and I I found the job wake up paid a lot
more I moved in a rooming house where
the toilets were in the hallway and I
saved every dollar after after a couple
of years I saved about
$5,000 I rented the garage actually it
was the gate House of standard products
in duffrin and tupon in
Toronto and I um the size was about
maybe double the the the garage I bought
a few used machines I had a $5,000 safe
up back in terms today that would be at
least 100 150,000 right so I bought the
huge machines and all they went hustling
I knocked on on Factory doors and they
said I'm I'm great in solving problems
and they said look if I can't solve the
problems you don't have to pay me but
anyway after one months I hired a work
after year about 10 workers after 2
years about 20 after 5 years about 3
4,000 after 10 years about
75,000 after 20 years
125,000
10 I buil up a company with
170,000 employees and 34 different
countries so anyway the message I want
to get across is
you know when we younger We All Hustle
to make some monies so that we can live
in
dignity I guess I could have lived in
dignity in all the 34 countries but I
choose Canada I think uh I I I've seen
the world and I met just about every
president uh you know from uh from
Clinton to Putin to Donny Blair just
about
everybody and I could see Canada perhaps
the only country now which could be a
role model which where we
could uh where we could Implement an
economic chter of Rights maget basically
is more than a business it's really a
culture I call it the F enterprise
system the basic philosophy and fair
Enterprise is the human chart of rights
at l Al is not sufficient we have to
fortify it with an economic CH of Rights
economic charters of Rights will to
economic democracies and economic
democracies are the basis for democracy
itself but let me explain it a little
better because uh we uh we don't talk
too much about it you know uh those
those conversations are not uh they're
not plold right but um let me simplify
things
now all the politician all business what
matter of fact most people agree if the
economy doesn't work nothing else will
work you cannot feed the hungry you
cannot look after the most fragile
people the elderly the sick and the
handicap but we do not talk what drives
the economy the economy is driven by
three
forces smart managers hardworking
employees and
investors that means all three have a
right to the outcome which is profits
the message I want to get across
is if we fail or if we do not let
workers participate in profits then we
got a problem okay because the world has
always been dominated by the Golden Rule
and still
is the people which have the gold make
the rules I don't want to be dominated
by anyone if I feel that strong then I
should not be able to dominate somebody
either so thereby the only way we be
able to achieve that is why an economic
CH of Rights the message I want to get
across to Canadians is the human chter
of Frights alone is not sufficient we
have to fortify it with an economic
chter of Frights economic CH frights as
I said before will lead to economic
democracies and economic democracies are
the basis for democracy itself the human
chart of Rights alone doesn't mean a lot
of things for kid inocent Detroit is
free to be
hungry so the amazing story about the
whole thing is
when I put in a corate constitution at
magne it was about in the mid late
80s the Constitution basically said or
what the most important thing on the on
the Constitution was we predetermined
what we do with the prophets so the the
Constitution said the the prophet
sharing said 20% of the profits go to
the shareholders 10% goes to the
employees over and above the we wages
half in shares half in cash 6%
management
gets 2% charity gets and 7% is
reinvested for for research so when I
put the
Constitution the profits went up the
first year about
40% the second year about 100% the third
year about
200% when you Empower employees
where they share where they where
there's a clear concept where they share
on the profits you release an enormous
energy you know because they're on the
front line the employees on the front
line they can see what you have to do to
make a better product for a better price
so that's what it's all about that's the
kind of C that's what the world needs
you know we stand perhaps at um at a
crossroad who will dominate the
world the United States is slipping to
certain extent the United States has
dominated the world for the last 100
years and where freedom and the
religious freedom freedom to speak and a
lot of freedom great right uh we have
maybe followed up and we could do a
little better there but United
States uh unfortunately
has a lot of problems there's cancer in
the inner cities the poverty is enormous
I don't know it's feasible right but the
very the the the very the key question
we have to ask
ourself what can we
do to uh you know because the Divide is
too great there so much money sell by
just a few and there's so much poverty
by many okay so what do we have to do to
to to level that out not completely you
can never you should never level it out
at the same time I say a country which
stles its citizen in pursuit of
productivity Ingenuity creativity is a
decaying this Society because you have
the society or the world's made up of
different Minds different desires
different let everybody choose their own
road to happiness okay so but it's very
important so I divide I divide actually
the program I classify business over 300
employees it's it's a large business
below 300 people it's a small
business the law would stipulate that
the large business which have more than
300 employees that they the law would
provide that workers could share in some
of the profits and that could be
determined right could be an escalated
program the small business uh small
business basically is the backbone of
any country this they pay the most taxes
they have the most
employment and this is where call it the
new products come forward the new te
knowy ET so we must do everything we can
that's that we take the red tapes off
take the chains of small business and
let small business operate under the
pure FR Enterprise principles so there
is the bureaucracy has climbed
enormously you know I could never build
a magnet anymore imagine starting out in
a garage imagine to build
170,000 employees over 400 factories
worldwide I could never because I would
choke under the first factory right and
I could give you examples now how how
cumbersome it is right okay and when we
look back 40 50 years yes we have a lot
of security uh uh our safety measurement
and you know buildings have to be built
that then will collapse over the snow
load Etc but the bureaucracy has climed
to such an extent but let me I I like to
point
out I to bring up a change you won't
bring up a change if you point the
fingers whose fault it is and you cannot
do it with the chains so either so I'm
saying it's not the fault of the Bure
the bureaucrats in a free Society
everybody has a right to find the job
whatever the job openings are it's the s
system the system we have to change our
politicians are trapped in the
systems because the politics is whoever
brings forward something new any
politician or party they won't win
because you could criticize them so this
is the problem uh politics government
can't fix things so it needs it's it
needs a private citizen it is it's a
coalition of what I would call concerned
Canadians which where you could leave
the program relative short that you
could combine this is what we need to
get the economy going because the
economy you know I I think it's it's
frightening what will happen over the
next 5 10 years we don't make things
anymore when you look when you see
factories the factories are all warehous
that we don't make things and when a
country doesn't make things they got to
inut everything then is where the
economy breaks down and where where
where there's no jobs where people go
hungry so we got to wait that so I think
have given you a a bit of a short
overview and uh I would be very happy to
now to answer questions and uh and uh
how can we how can we fix things okay so
I would like to know first of all what
skills you brought to Canada with you
and how long it took you to acquire
those skills say on the tool and die
maker side and then also what attitude
you think you brought to bear to your
work that enticed the first person for
example to offer you a partnership but
that also made you capable of taking the
risk and developing the vision to rent
that first empty garage so how were you
trained how long did that take what made
you a good potential partner and why did
you have enough daring let's say or
Vision to rent that first
garage well the training uh I I served
High School uh High School it was only
eight classes and I proposed to in
Canada we should uh high school should
end at grade 10 grade 11 and grade 12 we
should student should focus we should
teach him traits and that doesn't mean
that the students after grade 12
couldn't go to university I'm just now
uh telling people uh the situation I was
exposed to so it was a three and a half
year program we had one or two days
where we had theoretical stuff where we
had to be in classrooms and let's say
four days we were on the on in a
workshop on the floor learning different
things so that was the
program what did you learn what what
what skills did you
acquire it um tool making is sort of for
every you need let's say uh let's take
this pen here that's not made by hand
huh there's so much Precision so much
knowledge goes in a in a in a in a
writing band The the Ink's got to come
out for the next few months is such a
minute that just that you can read and
write so you got to make machines or
tools or or let's people might may
understand well let's say a bumper for a
car is not made by hand huh okay you
need a mold because it's plastic right
and it's h you so this is what d making
is about right and this is
um this is maybe the most important
trade uh to uh to get things done to get
things made right when you take uh when
you take a car might it be a door might
it be a seat might it be the pumper
right you need tools you need TI and
then special Machinery so that will call
it the basics would take 3 to four years
years and then it might take another few
years till you slowly work yourself up
that you be qualified to a die
[Music]
maker we're facing the threat of a
government shutdown later this month and
yet again the administration will
ultimately deal with it the same way
they always do with more spending more
spending equals a lower value of the
dollar protect your savings by
diversifying into gold with the help of
the Birch gold group and here's the best
part when you open a gold Ira with Birch
gold for every $10,000 you spend by
December 22nd Birch gold will send you a
free gold bar just text Jordan to
9898917350
navigate transitioning an existing Ira
or 401K into an IRA in Gold don't let
your savings become a victim of the
further devaluation of the dollar
through more spending text Jordan to
98 and so what machines did you learn to
operate when you were doing your
training and you also mentioned earlier
that you were confident in putting
yourself forward as a good Problem
Solver and so what was the relationship
between learning those machines when
what machines did you learn and how did
that facilitate your development as a
problem solver interesting the first
when I came out of high school my first
day at that factory you know I needed a
platform because I couldn't quite reach
up right I was 14 years of age I
couldn't reach up there was a vice grip
mounted on the thing here and then there
was a piece of Steel the piece of Steel
was about 4 in square okay okay we uh we
took two people to lift that steel P up
on on the vice grip and then we had a
then we had a hacksaw a metal hacksaw we
had to cut a piece down 4 in
square and that took uh that took maybe
a week okay till we cut the thing down
and then it took maybe about three four
weeks we had to file it perfectly Square
so that mean it's amazing thing what
that leads to and how you accumulate the
Precision work right I did a similar
School in Canada where we where we we
had a school here to teach young kids
how to be D and Di makers right but
anyway so you go and then we learn we
learn things on the late where you make
run things or milling machine and later
on uh I uh computerized machines etc etc
so you go to a stage right okay so
anyway that's what we uh I did my first
job then in Toronto as a Dulan D maker
we made a Stampy die right we to maybe
Punch Out pie of metal and with some
holes in it and so that's
basically uh what the dollar die maker
does and as as you go along it gets more
and more
sophisticated right right so you got you
got familiarized with a wide variety of
tools and the ability to make Precision
parts now you said you also became a
good Problem Solver and then you also
developed this idea that you could rent
your own garage and start producing your
own tools now one of the things you said
was that when you went out to sell your
services you told your potential
customers that you could solve a problem
and if you didn't they didn't have to
pay you and you know the reason I want
to focus on that in part is because I
want to know how you develop the vision
to rent that garage to begin with but
also H how you knew that the proper
thing to sell to potential customers was
your service as a problem solver right
because what you're saying to them
essentially is well you guys have a
problem and it's plaguing you and you
need it solved and I'm the guy that can
solve it and I'm willing to you know
demonstrate my capabilities which is
which is really an excellent approach to
sales because you want to find out what
the person's problem is and you want to
be the solution but how did you develop
that problem solving ability and your
confidence in it and then why did you
think it was worth taking the risk to
rent that first
garage Jordan you ask great questions
you me those have to be answered the
reason why I'm sitting here is look I
want to roll off the experience I accum
ated there's thousands and thousands and
thousands of young Canadians out there
which could do the same thing if we if
we teach them the basics right and I I
think a society would be much better off
with thousands of smaller companies than
one or two large companies right that's
what that's that's the idea so anyway so
I opened up that factory I I could solve
a few problems I got some Waters and I I
I like I said after two years I had
about 20 people and I noticed my foran
was a little different right because
when he had just got you worked so
closely together his name was Herman I
said Herman what's the matter with you
lately well he said Frank I'm thinking
of opening my own Factory hm I said I
sympathize with that I that's what I did
to I said look why don't we talk
tomorrow maybe we can find a better
solution that evening I was talking to
myself and I said to myself that if that
foran's going to leave me that would
stifle my grow I didn't like that the
next reason was if that Foreman's going
to leave me I got to do all the work
myself I like to if less the third
reason was if I hire a new foreman and I
don't show him how to how to run the
business I still got it all the work and
I if I hire a new foran and I show him
how businesses run it's just a question
of time before he goes out it opens up
his new Factory I I think the key is we
need we we need those experience there
is there is this huge potential right
this huge energy which lies dor in
people we got to teach them the right
way so I think it's important while I'm
still I have everything in my mind quite
clearly that we record that and it's
great that you your skill is to to ask
the right question how come and how what
right okay so I'm I'm delighted to sit
here well so you you grew very rapidly
so so there's two Mysteries there to me
because one of the things I've noticed
with small businesses for example is
that it's very difficult to get your
first customers right it's very
difficult to get from zero to one once
you have a customer or two the next
customers start to be easier because you
can refer them to other customers you
have but getting those first people to
decide that you're the person when no
one else has done it or has has been
willing to show that faith that can be
very tricky so what do you think you
manage
successfully to how do you think you
managed to present yourself successfully
to the first people that you offered
your services to
well sprice and quality doesn't function
right and if you have a lot of knowledge
and you and you transmit that knowledge
to other people then you then you can
give a great service better pricing uh
better functioning Machinery ped tools
so that's the very key and that's what I
would like to
transmit so uh
fortunately um around that time that's
why I'm always saying life is a question
of fate and circumstances being at the
right place at the right time around in
in the early 60s you know there was a
free trade Arrangement signed with the
United
States and uh and I see this huge
potential out there I should say I
didn't finish up when I talked the next
day with my foreman where yeah where I
said I said to him look why don't we
open up a new Factory you're own the
third and I said no more overtime I own
2/3 and by by the end of the year we
take Pro rers some monies out and we
leave some money in for expansions he
said do you mean it I said yes we went
right away to a lawyer and signed the
thing here and the guy hustled like
crazy you know he spent more diam in
there that was his Factory basically I
took the next format the next form and
the next form the next form I said
business is easy right and then uh when
I had about I think it was about uh six
or seven
factories and the the free trade
Arrangement uh came under the being I
saw there's enormous potential up there
up to that now I only shared with the
foran I said if I and then I got to know
uh the United States Better Canada
better the the power of the unions the
size of the unions and I said if I if I
uh I would have to do certain things to
be
competive so um I um I had a friend of
mine machinery taer and he said I I kind
of explain to him I really shook go
public because I want to have the
workers also
participate well he says I know a I know
a fellow which his name is uh I'll
remember it's imel but anyway he gave me
the name I I met him uh at the ski hill
uh we went skiing to get up at uh at
church beaks and uh he said look have uh
that was magnet Electronics okay he said
I have a certain I would like to R why
do you why don't you sell your companies
in in in in magnet electronics and and
you have Clues to control and then you
could put that program in that where we
also where you can share the profits
with workers so that's what I finally
did that I was totally grean when it
comes down to public company right uh I
did not have total control I had a
bought there right and they were more in
um driving the stock up right in and the
def the defense industry was very uh
they were mainly magnet electronic did
mainly Defense work right and that was
very popular and I was an automotive and
I said after a year so I said I don't
think this makes a lot I said um I I I
want to be out okay and I said I sell my
stock on the on on on the market so they
pleaded with me please sell the stock to
us so they said fine no problem and uh
give us a year time and I said fine they
were basically okay guys but the market
kind of went down uh the shares there
they didn't have the monies I never suit
anybody and I just said look under the
circumstances you guys can't be on the
board and then I put in different
directors and after a while I went to
the to the board and read to the public
and say I for I for go about uh 25% of
my stocks if you the shareholders vote
for multiple
vote because I came to the conclusion I
want to run things and I can't have 20
guys or 50 guys left and right
discussing debating forever right so uh
I uh
I the shareholders voted for that then I
said I in the return I also give fting a
certain discipline this is why I put the
cor constitution in that if I had
control I only could take out so much
there was uh clearcut control what
management uh could
do and that sort of uh became the the
Magna the the Magna environment but the
yeah well let's go back back to your
Foreman so you had said that when you
made that arrangement with him that you
valued his work and you wanted him
around and you were concerned that if he
left while all of that work would fall
on your shoulders again and also stop
you from moving ahead and you sat down
and contemplated what sort of deal you
would have to make with him in order for
his needs to be met in yours and there's
something very important there about the
nature of a deal you know people often
think that with a deal you try to win or
with a deal you try to compromise but my
sense with the proper negotiation is
that you want to figure out what you
want so that you're thrilled to progress
with the deal and you want to figure out
what your partner wants so he's thrilled
to progress with the deal because if you
set it up that way then your interests
are aligned and you're both going to
work as hard as you can autonomously now
you knew your foremen had the same kind
of entrepreneurial Vision you did and
you wanted to unleash his abilities and
so you offered him a third of the
company you said you'd take two3 and
then you said he was thrilled which is a
good thing to have happen in a partner
and he went off and like treated this
Factory like it was his own partly
because it was
now and then you said you you duplicated
that subsidiary structure across six
factories and then expanded much more
dramatically and you also at that point
also noted that that principle of
distributed ownership should be brought
down to the workers so you were starting
to develop that as an explicit
philosophy
now why why do you think it was that you
realized that your Foreman needed
ownership why do you think you were
willing to Grant it to him and why do
you think that the agreement that you
made which was that you would own oneir
of the or that he would own one3 of the
company and you would own 2/3 why do you
think that was a desirable and and uh a
compelling motivational arrangement for
your
Forman first of all a deal you got to be
a deal for both sides it's got to be
good right and as a company grows
circumstances may change a bit etc etc
so you make Provisions if you can the
reason why I think
he he was delighted with the deal is
uh when we had verbal
Arrangements I never went back on my w I
think that's a very key right so he felt
comfortable when they say we take out
the third right uh we we take out a
portion in brada so he felt kind of
comfortable right that I uh that I uh
that's that's very crucial like later on
if I if you know once when I had about
30 40 or 50 or 100 factories and I had a
prospective manager which I interviewed
I said look there's there the name the
addresses of 100
factories whoever manager you want to
want to choose and and ask him how I run
things okay the message what I wanted to
get across if you promise something
thing you must keep it doesn't matter
what the thing is
because you if you got the ability can
always make monies if you lose your
reputation you can never
repair so I think I had a reputation
buil up and again when it said uh small
companies you don't need uh you don't
need a formal structure it's kind of
loose it's pure free enterprise like
when was small when I had about 20 30 or
40 work CU I showed you my bank book and
said look this is our contract we have
here if you do XXX I shareed with you
right so you don't it's pure free
enterprise and that's what I want to get
across that's pure capitalism but
capitalism if it don't change if you do
not look like workers participate
capitalistic the system is
self-destructive and let me give you a
quick story right I spent a lot of time
in Washington at one time had a meeting
with the leader of the House Mitch
McConnell he's the senator from Kentucky
he was the president of the Senate I had
a farm in Kentucky so I knew him so I
said Mitch Let's uh you know I like to
see you one of those days so we arranged
I met him and they said Mitch America
did create why the free enterprise
system and without free enterprise
there's no free Society so we must do do
everything we can to have free
enterprise but he said free enterprise
got a major problem so he said what you
mean by that I said MCH more and more
capital is helped by fewer and fewer and
I said I said in nature when a species
does not reproduce itself another
species will take over and the laws of
nature are much stronger than any man
weight law right and that's what happens
now that's the way we going to go so we
got to share with the employees because
without employees we can't make a profit
and if employees make more money they
have more purchasing power the economy
functions better okay so we must we must
have the large companies they must have
more of a discipline because they
sometimes they run by institutions by by
and they have got no more affinity for
people that they just look at the share
price they look at the the prophets so
it's not there right so uh the owners
are not there anymore or so anyway we
need the discipline there but but we
must open up we must it's it's so
crucial that small Enterprise that we
don't D them up in Chains and with
regulations the Bible is the root of all
wisdom inspiration and spiritual
nourishment the hall app empowers you to
explore the Bible's profound teachings
and to effortlessly incorporate them
into your daily life a great place to
start while you deepen your
understanding of the Bible is to check
out father Mike Schmid's Bible in a year
available on the Hallow app for brief
daily readings and Reflections here you
can dive into an extensive library of
Bible reading plans accompanied by
insightful Reflections and Audi guided
meditations whether you're a seasoned
Bible reader or just starting your
journey hallow provides a platform for
you to engage with scripture like never
before studying the Bible's literary
Brilliance has influenced countless
writers poets and artists throughout
history by studying the Bible yourself
you'll gain a deeper appreciation for
the power of Storytelling symbolism and
metaphor enriching your understanding of
literature across different genres the
Hallow app also helps you connect with a
community of like-minded individuals
sharing experiences insights and
encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth download the app for
free at hall.com Jordan you can set
reminders and track your progress along
the way enrich your education and
nurture your mind and soul today down
the Hallow app at hall.com Jordan that's
hall.com
Jordan hall.com Jordan for an exclusive
3-month free trial of all 10,000 plus
prayers and
meditations okay now you
highlighted you highlighted three things
you know the first thing you highlighted
was that the people that you were
negotiating could trust you now people
who are
cynically um critical of capitalism
tend to justify that by noting the sort
of winner take all problem that you
described and then they presume that if
you're greedy and you shovel everything
towards yourself you're most likely to
let's say win in the capitalist
Enterprise but you pointed out something
very much contrary to that three things
actually the first is that you don't
develop a reputation by screwing other
people you develop a reputation by
telling other people what you're going
to do and then bloody well doing it and
that you should also write down what you
say you're going to do so that everybody
remembers and knows exactly what the
deal is that you said that by the time
you were negotiating let's say with a
foreman who wanted to leave you had
enough track record with him of trust so
that he believed that you would do what
you said you were going to do and he
could Envision a future with you without
having to worry about your motivations
so you established your trust then you
also realized that he was going to be a
hell of a lot more motivated if he was
an owner in the system right right and
so your answer to the problem of
capitalism isn't exactly less capitalism
it's a much more distributed and
generous form of capitalism that pulls
everybody the workers and in managers
and owners into the profit making
structure now you now the other
Advantage this is so cool I because I've
learned this as I've built Enterprises
too if you make a really great deal with
someone and the person's good and
they're competent and they're honest and
they're productive and they're generous
if you make a really good deal with them
and you can let them go off on their own
that means that they're going to take
care of a thousand details on their own
keeping their own Affairs in order that
you don't have to take care of anymore
you don't have to micromanage and that
means that you can go off and you know
expand your Enterprise and do your own
thing and so the advantage you gain by
Distributing more responsibility let's
say to an extremely competent Foreman
the advantage you gain is massive
freedom and you also gain the advantage
of the fact that that foreman who now
partakes in the Enterprise is going to
be much more motivated to make the
Enterprise work and so even if you end
up paying him more like a third of the
company let's say or the profit share
that you described the overall profit is
going to be so much greater that there's
nothing in it but benefit for you and
for him and then you also pointed out
and this is a very crucial thing for
people to understand because this is
where the left-wing critic critics of C
capitalism actually have a point
although it's not a problem that's
specific to capitalism which is that as
an Enterprise grows and it doesn't
matter what the Enterprise is the
benefits tend to flow into the hands of
fewer and fewer people and that
destabilizes the whole damn Enterprise
because you get too many slaves on the
bottom and not enough pharaohs on the
top and that produces discontent and
dissatisfaction and a motivation and
that can bring the whole damn system to
a halt so you're
Your solution to that was to set up this
Constitution that you described which
also enabled you to grow I'm going to
review it again because it's very very
important this is the economic Charter
of Rights so your management philosophy
is to distribute
responsibility and profit and to make
that an explicit part of the agreement
and the deal is 20% of the profits go to
the
shareholders
6% to the management 10% to the workers
2% to charity 7% reinvested in um
research and further development and you
make That explicit now the trust you
described is also crucial because the
workers with whom you're arranging to
share the profits aren't going to trust
that deal or go along with it if they
think you're going to gerrymander the
books on the profit side right they have
to have actually believe that you're
going to play a straight game but if you
can explain to them that well you're
going to play a straight game because if
you motivate them properly they're going
to work Ah hell of a lot harder and
everybody's going to make a lot more
money and the products are going to have
higher quality and we're going to sell
more then there's absolutely nothing
there for people to you know steal
selfishly and run away with there's only
the possibility that all that
distributed responsibility and ability
is going to produce more and more well
it's going to be more and more
productive and more and more generous
now I asked you when we met at the
restaurant a couple of months ago
whether or not you had run into labor
problems as you grew because going from
you know no employees to 100,000 you're
obviously going to be dealing with
potential labor issues and you'' said
that as a consequence of this
Constitution and the trustworthiness of
the process that you've had that you've
been able to pay your workers a premium
rate but that you've also had almost no
labor trouble is that is that correct if
I got that right yeah that's that is
correct cor and uh the interesting part
about it
is uh we were basically in the
automobile industry and the order
Workers Union was maybe the strongest
Union in America right okay so
anyway um the president of the Canadian
order Workers Union his name was basag
or still is in is his name and I called
him and I said MERS let's have lunch the
two of us we have an
obligation uh what are we going to do to
maintain jobs and create new jobs I said
let's have lunch so we agreed and then
we sat down and said bu it shouldn't be
that difficult to put on one page what's
important for the workers and on one
page what's important for business and
we call that a framework of economic
Justice after a few weeks we we we
managed it a bit we agreed on the thing
on on on that structure he said to me I
I might not get a true to my
membership okay and but he did get it
through and
we we incorporated that huh we took two
factories where we said look we're going
to try and see how that works right
the part was our workers were very upset
they said look all we we find we are
happy you want to change a total
different thing here I took I took a I
said look I have an obl an obligation we
live in a society we are a very
important part of that Society we got to
find ways and means can we learn from
that right because when I made my you
know if you have a few 100 factories
when I made my rounds I made it a haveit
always to at least uh every months I see
maybe a new a factory which I haven't
seen for a while when I made my rounds I
got the workers together and they said
look those are the basic principles but
they said let's make one thing clear no
government can guarantee your chops no
Union can guarantee your chobs not even
magnet can guarantee a chobs but I'm the
head of the magnet I can guarantee one
thing the basic
principles and that is the very key as
it is if we if labor and man management
work together and make a quality product
that's the best
guarantee that's the best guarantee and
we can make the quality product if we if
we
communicate and we put a very important
structure in in our company right we
ordered the human
capital it's a very it's a very unusual
thing here first of all I put in a
hotline I had some trusted
people and we got a big uh notice on and
and uh in the factories if you're
unhappy
with something that something
discrimination or unfairness or woman
get bested by whatever it is call a
hotline but you don't have to give your
name and I had people then investigate
those were thrusted
people and now when I would talk with
managers they said that's one of the
best things you did because the first
reaction when it did that they said the
man said are you spying on us they were
unhappy but now it's other because if
you have an unhappy
employee unhappiness is contagious if
you got unhappy employees there's no way
you can make a quality product at a
competitive price so that's very uh so
we've done that on a verbal thing where
we have a then we did
actually an a
uh
written a human audit where an employee
got
anope with no name on it no no and they
could take it home and fill it out you
know various question is it safe is it
fair discrimination or whatever you
could fill it out and there's only one
in in in in an envelope no name on it
and you drop it in a in a box and it's
collected and then we analyze it and we
could see right away if there was a
problem okay we could see it so that is
another worry uh because as a manager
let's
say uh the average Factory was about 200
people in hour in hour and that's
another very important thing to become I
always had efficiency experts come to me
Christ together with 400 factors reduce
it you know reduce it maybe to 20 or
whatever that means to have maybe maybe
5 10,000 people per Factory people
become a number it doesn't work it
doesn't work right so
we look you should never forget the
human side right by having smaller
factories and we let's say the factor is
located more in the Northerly region
it's run like a factory right if hunting
season comes and some people want to
take some time off other people jump in
I said like I cover for you I work the
extra time it's it's it's everything
relates the people to work has got to be
an equal and I said to myself and I said
to the managers your number one thing is
every day you got to work are you
respected by the
workers that's your main
name you got got to be respected and
once when you build that thing then you
be productive right you be they think of
the workers think of better ways to make
things right and there and business is
easy all you have to do is make a better
product for a better price that's as
easy as it
is according to a recent report Planned
Parenthood continues to rake in billions
despite dwindling clients the biggest
takeaway here is that Planned Parenthood
is gener generating vast profits
including millions in taxpayer funding
with the help of pre-born you and me we
are stealing their clientele meaning the
babies they are trying to kill pre-born
operates on a very slim budget as they
rescue over 200 babies lives every day
and they receed no Government funding
pre-born network of clinics are situated
in the darkest corners competing
head-to-head with the abortion Giants
they need our help now more than ever
when you donate $28 to pre-born you will
offer a free ultrasound to expectant
mother caught in crisis once she hears
that Harpy and sees that precious life
her baby's chance at life doubles if you
would like to sponsor a precious baby's
life your gift will be tax deductible
and will go directly towards saving
babies lives dial pound 250 and say the
keyword baby or visit preborn
docomo all gifts are tax deductible you
will never regret saving a child's life
that's pound 250 baby or visit preborn
doccom
Jordan so you pointed out there are a
number of things that are extremely
interesting so one of them imagine that
you're trying to differentiate your
Enterprise as it grows you have 100,000
employees and obviously there has to be
a hierarchy between you and them the
question is what size should the pieces
of that hierarchy be you know there's an
anthropological literature that
relates cortical expansion so brain size
to average group size in primate
communities and the optimized group size
for human beings seems to be something
around 200 what generally happens in
Hunter gather societies is that if a
society exceeds about 200 individuals
it'll break into two separate societies
that's very common and I think the
reason for that is well I think the
reason for that is the one that you just
pointed out is that there's a once a
network of associations gets to be too
big
you stop having that personal connection
with people and you start to become a
number like I've certainly seen this in
educational institutions you know the
huge universities reduce the University
students to numbers they're irrelevant
there's no personal relationship and so
the students end up feeling alienated
and that demolishes their motivation and
you know in the typical educational
apparatus in the higher education field
you have a 40% Dropout in the first year
and that OB that's a catastrophic figure
and I know a college um Hillsdale
College is small place it's only got
12200 people and it's hierarchically
organized they've managed to get their
dropout rate down to 1% so 40% is an
absolute crime now you how do you do you
talked about human audit you also talked
about allowing employees to put forward
their concerns and and and and to
indicate their unhappiness with process
and to bring new ideas to the Forefront
without having to worry that they were
going to be targeted for doing so and
that was very effective so you set up
communication networks in your factories
and you kept them small so you could do
that how do you guys do in terms of
employee wages in terms of per capita
employee productivity and with regard to
turnover well uh first of I want to
listen to you there is in universities
uh lecture course or what what is the
optimum uh people uh on the leadership
Etc and how many people are below or
whatever it's 200 right so I should go
back to school to maybe learn more about
that so that's but in in in practice you
you you you you get to know you learn as
you go along in practice uh in every
business might be a little different
right okay but in now thing it it what I
could see about a factory with 200
people the manager had to again and
practic know everybody by his first name
and how is how is Billy your son how is
he in football it's it's that kind of
environment right a chel and not not a
phony one right not not a phony one
because employees will realize if it's
phony you know or if it's genuinely me
right it's very crucial right
so so anyway um over the years I gave a
lot of lectures in universities and
always starts the the students when they
started out the success of Life can only
be measured the degree of happiness you
reach you have but I said let me tell
you from my experience it's a lot easier
to be happy if you got some monies the
smart students always if ask well how
can we make some money is so I said Lu
if you be around 20 in your early 20s
you don't know yourself that well
experiment a bit do something what you
enjoy when you enjoy something you're
going to be good in it if you put in the
extra effort you could be one of the
best whatever it is if you be one of the
best money is a byproduct but I said but
one thing don't
forget you must not forget get life has
been great to you your parent sacrificed
that you perhaps went to school you have
a right to use that knowledge what you
accumulated in school for your own
benefits but never forget a portion of
that wisdom of that knowledge got to go
back to
Society for to a better
Society but the very interesting thing
is it's only the last number of years I
came to the
conclusion that look we have no
faculties right they mean as far as I un
as as I can see universities their
mandate is to teach young people can we
have a more civilized
society or be more
specific can we teach young people can
we as a university
participate to develop a structure which
could lead to anide
society that should be the main focus of
of a university yes we in universities
we teach great medicine and great art
great sport great
technology but we do not teach you know
what is the structure of an ideal
Society but it don't me in the United
States about 70% of the universities are
subsidized for private IND industry and
in Canada 100% under the provincial
jurisdiction okay 100%
subsidized and management doesn't
doesn't want to bite the hand which
feeds
them okay but luckily I could I could
convince the minister of
Education of of of
universities till around and uh I think
I'm doing a series in search of the
ideal structure which would lead to
night till
satday your your workers um you've had
little labor trouble
formally how do you know that your
workers are in fact like comparatively
well paid in relationship to other
Enterprises of your type and how do you
guys do in terms of retention and
promotion well we have uh we do
constantly a survey the corporate
Constitution says the wages got the be
average to the competition within the
region and the profits uh the profets at
lay town we had a formula it's not up to
a manager say I like that person or this
or that she's beautiful or whatever uh
it's we have a formula the formula was
based based upon we wanted to reward
loyalty and suppose you get a point for
year you've been with the company
suppose you've been with the company
five years you get five points for
loyalty and suppose you get a point for
the $5,000 you earn and suppose you earn
50,000 you get them points for knowledge
right and the more points you have uh
the more you share out of the out of the
B right but it's preformulated right so
we want to we want to reward loyalty and
performance
the managers are separate right they
purely they purely particip participate
in their Factory I've always said there
is no bad employees only bad
managers and the bad
or there's very few bad manage or let me
rephrase it there's few uh there's some
managers which need more learning
experience right but there's very few
bad man but there's no bad employees
okay
because we uh it's our thing to it's
it's it's our thing to assist them in in
learning and what makes a factory run
and they care I guess as a businessman
it's what makes the economy run in a
country the the economy we need a new
model of the economy and I I I think I
Canada could be the first country
with uh with an economic CH of Rights it
an economic charters of Rights it's
fundamental how many companies okay
you've had a lot of success with this
particular model of corporate governance
and it's allowed you to grow very
rapidly to to develop a very large
Enterprise and to maintain it across now
quite a long time because it's about 50
years 70 years 70 years that's very long
in the corporate world how widespread
have your ideas of constitutional profit
sharing become and what H in your view
has been the impediment to their wider
acceptance well keep in mind I was for
many years on the corporate governance
Board of nastic or the New York Stock
Exchange okay where we take a look uh
minority interest or or the market not
uh behaving properly right and we worked
at we interfaced with the sex Security
Commission and and brought forward that
the market needs changing okay there's
no different in in in in here it's it's
a constant and it should be done within
within the company right and uh so it's
expected that the management uh live to
certain standards employees have to live
in society we have to teach standards we
have to uh
we we don't teach enough our kids what
it's all about okay and U I moved to
after I finished my schooling in Austria
I moved to Switzerland right uh and um I
U it was a a great learning experience
it's a great country with great people
it's made relative easy to to to to
demand a
referendum
okay and so on important things they
have a r referendums said about two
years I I think it was in the wall stre
Journal Swiss Swiss people defeated the
referendum to have more vacation I think
the referendum was to move the vacation
up from 3 weeks to five weeks the the
people defeated it and said we cannot
afford it right right it's the ultimate
democracy
so why why why have the ideas that
you've put forward in relationship to
the corporate Constitution not being
accepted and implemented by more
companies do you think I mean your model
has shown that if you're more generous
with the profit distribution and if you
formalize that distribution you seem to
gain an increment productivity and so
why also given the fact that you know
Capital tends to acre in the hands of
fewer and fewer people what and that
that's a problem for the maintenance of
the popularity of the capitalist system
in general why do you think your
economic model hasn't met with more
acceptance is it just that it's too new
you know I mean new new ideas take a
long time to distribute what's the
impediment sure I wrot a book to Greed
Factor right and Homo sapiens are born
with some greed without greed homo saion
cannot
exist and uh but greed after a certain
thing it's the most destructive for us
so uh like I said I've pinned uh on the
corporate governance Bo it's what an
education we've make it too complicated
for public companies right the
paragraphs like I mean it's it's so
complicated that uh um it's just a fe
anymore right so young entrepreneurs
think Ah that's it's it's and and so
everything is more complicated so we got
to get back again and there was nothing
wrong with Canada about uh about 40 50
60 years
ago uh so uh everything functioned quite
well so we have we have gotten into that
uh where we where we analyze where we
where
we look when you look at
our what the best the best way to to
bring it across is when you take a look
our our Dax code codex it's a deck book
with thousands of
paragraphs keep in mind when I fully run
maget I had 20 lawyers on one side of my
office and 20 Financial exports just on
the other
side when I went to the lawyers since I
like to do XXX is that within the law
why say that's within the law I went to
the thing here now how is it treated
from a tax point of view after after a
week you know you got the thing it's so
comply it's so gray it could be the way
but they said there's some there's some
experts down in the city which uh so you
gift you you you you sent them the
problem or the clarification after a few
weeks they get a Big Bill and they they
can be either way so everything every
every paragraph there's there's
thousands and thousands they more
convoluted than the others until we have
a a tax system black and white where
every can fill out down we have how can
a society function the Dax system is is
slandered in favor of of of uh
specialized interest groups that's the
Dilemma Al so you mentioned earlier in
our conversation that you believe that
it would be very difficult for you to
start your you know dual
garage basic Factory today that the
regulatory burden would be just too high
and so you know as societies move
forward in time they tend to acrew more
and more rules right they tend to
stagnate themselves and that's a
constant danger I mean one of the
advantages to the capitalist system is
that large unwieldy Enterprises that no
longer function get killed by the market
and disappear and we don't really have
an equivalent function of death let's
say in the bureaucratic realm we have
elections but that doesn't really affect
the bureaucratic state do you have any
sense of how it might be possible to
clear out some of the regulations that
are impeding entrepreneurial development
and do you have you had any success in
talking to politicians let's say in
Canada about how that some of that house
cleaning might
occur the politicians can't do it I
could give you many reasons or maybe
some other times we have a little more
time but again I want to point out no
chainsaw approach every it's not the
fault of the bureaucrats it's the fault
of the system but one be a civilized way
will be not to rehire till he reach a
certain status right and it's got to
relate to the gitt
to uh you know to the to the to the GDP
to uh what we what we can create it
needs X same as a a management needs X
manages the same a society could have
where on the bureaucratic side a certain
percentage related to to the market to
what does the country
produce let's talk a little bit about
the future now one of the things we
discussed when we first met was a new
product that you're bringing to Market
and um on on the cheap and easily
accessible Transportation side
especially for urban commuters do you
want to talk about the product that you
guys are bringing to Market soon and and
where you're going to build that and
what your vision is for that yes about
two years ago the premier called me and
he said I got a problem I said what he
said Channel Motors is closing you know
the car industry
I got inducted in the American
Automotive h of Fame in
2018 so I said yeah give me give me a
few days give me a week I'll bring
forward something at around that time I
I had to go down down a few times I
should say the Magna head office is an
aurora which is about um uh about 21
minutes down to the 41 right uh so
anyway around that time I had to go down
down a few times would used to take me
half an hour from the outer ring to the
inner ring to Bay Street now would take
if everything is fine would take an hour
but you could take two hours so I got
stuck a few times two hours and I said
what a what a waste of human energy what
a waste of of nonrenewable energies but
most of all what a what a to inhale the
carbon monoxide for two hours on the way
in two hours home you know I said what
what damage that does to to to to the to
the health to the wellbeing of people so
anyway I went back to the workbench okay
I should say Magna is a major Cafe
manufacturing company we have one
Factory where we produce all the Mini
Coopers for the whole world that be
shipped out of out of our factories
right under the showrooms right across
the world we developed the a Martin to
repeat you know right from our Factory
sh Shi to the showrooms a very unique
car no welding no screwing it was built
like an airplane it was glued together
right but anyway so I I I I think uh
I've done that for 60 years I came to
the conclusion it's got to be a small
electric car I think we qu the phrase
micromobility
and in loose terms micro Mobility means
you need uh you you got to be able to
park at least four of those in a regular
car parking spot to be more precise if
they cannot be wider than three and A2
ft not longer than 7 ft and you can plug
it in in any electrical out Outlet 1
then W and uh in a few hours you can go
100 Kil kilometers with it for less than
a dollar you can have a quick charging
too so it will change uh
Transportation its main purpose is to
get people from your home to your
workplace and back home we also done an
equivalent small pick pickup truck which
will do in City uh merchandise
delivery and I should be in mass
production about 2 three months uh the
fact is just around we got the first
brother dice coming after
L and it will change uh it will change
uh transportation for many reasons the
primary reason
is there's only so much oil in the
grounds the reason why gasoline prices
are relative cheap years the United
States is utilizing 120 million tons of
grain to convert it into ethanol to keep
the gasoline price down you can't do
that for long because the next wave will
be Or the critical wave for society will
be food shortages in the world not
triggered by the UK it would have come
anyway but will be accelerated quicker
by what goes on in the Ukraine because
the Ukraine is a major food producer so
and the United States can't do that so
the gasoline prices will up dramatically
I would say will double in two three
years but most of all I predicted 8
years gasoline will be rationalized will
only be available for essential purposes
one of the essential purpose will be
electric trucks not electric butd me
gasoline trucks will hold the food from
the Farms to the cities because the the
crit power will not be there for large
electric trucks or you will not solve
the traffic change because there is the
crit power isn't there it would take
much time to to and you might have to go
with small atomic power stations right
but that but that's that's another thing
here right but the git system isn't
there at uh I built the first hydrogen
car with
BMW about uh yeah about 15 years ago yes
it works but much more Compass are much
more
expensive and I I see a small electric
car you know uh uh that's the answer for
now for the next 50 hundred years do you
want to talk a little bit about what it
looks like and and and and what people
can expect what people can expect to see
and experience when they when they use
this particular vehicle okay they're
basically small right
we again its main purpose is to go from
your home to your workplace and back
home okay and that mean means we have
stifled uh the the speed at 32 kilm per
hour right so basically the insurance be
so minimal of practically none because
you can't do any
damage so and
um two people can sit in a car and
people in a pickup truck there's four
people can sit in there it could be a
taxi it could be a uh uh you know
merchandise delivery uh
vehicle so um yeah I think we we have uh
we showed it on the Canadian Auto Show
we had the biggest lineups and thousands
of people drove it they got all
enthusiastic about it and um the key
question is how do we got to get around
that's the key question right well it
looked like it looked like a kind of of
a hybrid between electric car and a and
a motorcycle essentially and the you
mentioned as well you know that many
families have a conundrum where because
there are two people working and they
tend to work in different locations that
they need two vehicles and one of the
vehicles and both vehicles are very
expensive and they're they're
overdetermined for the purpose people
need um a commuter vehicle essentially
as well as an ordinary vehicle to do all
the other things they need to do with it
and your sense was that this vehicle
would Supply a lowcost alternative to
people who need primarily need
transportation to work and back and who
wouldn't be using the vehicle who would
be using their other vehicle for primary
purposes other than that does that seem
about right uh a few changes uh when I
look when I look down the road uh now
usually call it the metal glasses of two
car garage two cars right
because um the husband May went to work
in must some cases the the the wife do
but in many cases the wife stayed home
she kids had to bring their kids to
school or the shopping etc etc so when I
look down the road I think I need a
special permit for a large electric car
for a family that you could go to the
cottage or that for special purpose not
for daily commute huh okay and you have
two or three uh you can in you could
actually could get four small cars in
there in a regular two car garage
and this is where cats or see their
friends or where the wife or the husband
go shopping so you to run around right
to to things meet up with your friends
and go to school or whatever go to work
and just uh it's reliable transport at
at low cost and no l cleanhouse CES I
would I would like to thank you very
much for the time you spent today I I
very think it's very useful to explain
to people I think it's extremely useful
to have explained to people uh CH I
don't want to flatter you you are gifted
to bring out the inner workings of of a
lot of Machinery a lot of people and
that's you know as a technician yes i'
be able to trans reasonable well but you
have a gift to transmit it that it be
easily understood by the people so I'm
delighted that I came I'm delighted that
I was
invited well it's it's so what what
struck me in our conversations was the
importance of disseminating your vision
for fostering a generous productivity
you know you created an Enterprise
that's distributed you said that you've
made millionaires out of many of your
foremen out of people who Rose to the
position where they could run their own
factories you you've given people the
opportunity to have a tremendous amount
of autonomy under your overarching
Authority and to bring out the best of
them as they build their own factories
and as they employ more and more people
and you've managed also to distribute
that responsibility and opportunity all
the way down to the workers and you know
it's absolutely obvious to me that
there's never been a more effective
machine for producing wealth than the
free exchange capitalist system the data
on that are crystal clear as soon as you
stop countries from doing absolutely
idiotic economic things and free up
their population under a quasi
capitalist market then everybody becomes
richer you then you have the emergent
problem of inequality and that's a
problem but your system of distributed
profits given that it's honestly run is
a reasonable solution to that problem
and it's it's very good to hear you talk
about how motivated you've been to build
the company and and to produce all the
products you have but also how much
you've been able to motivate other
people while being productive and
solving the problem of unequal
distribution so thank you very much for
bringing that to everyone's attention I
I got I got I had a few more words my
motivation was never to be hungry
anymore and live in dignity and the
reason is it's very important if a
manager let's say a magnet manager
wanted to make more money he had to
replace himself and has to open up
another Factory so a manager could
replace himself maybe 20 30 or 50 times
and then he gets a cut from each Factory
where he made a contribution a
percentage of the profits and this way
some of them uh their yearly income
maybe was 5 million or 10 million so the
more they made the more the shareh
olders made the more more workers made
so we when I said it's so important that
we have that we have smaller companies
that young kids got to see I want to be
able to do like like CH BR I want to I
want to make 50 million or 100 million
or or like the football player like the
hockey player we must give him the
motivation right but Let It Be Right
some people are quite happy with XXX let
it be let everybody I love the Beet
their song let it be let it be let
everybody be let everybody be let
everybody find their own rate their
happiness thank you my pleasure man to
everybody watching and listening thank
you very much for your time and
attention the film crew up here in
Northern Ontario and uh down where Frank
is thank you for the Flawless technical
um the provision of flawless teex
technical expertise on this front to the
Daily we Plus for making these
conversations possible I'm going to
continue talking to Mr Frank stronic for
another half an hour on the dailywire
plus platform um a Bastion of free
speech in an increasingly sensorial
world and so if those of you who are
watching and listening are inclined to
devote your attention uh to that
platform that would be much appreciated
and maybe increasingly necessary as the
months unfold um I'm looking forward to
coming and looking at your factory Mr
stronic I think that would be very much
fun it's I I love looking at Industrial
Enterprises because
well it's lovely to see that much
concerted and harmonious effort working
out to produce things that people
actually need I really wish you luck
with your new vehicle um I I hope that
you've hit the market dead on and that
people find this vehicle you know
inexpensive reliable and useful like
many of your other products have been
and so that would be a lovely thing to
see it would be great to see that
happening in Canada because uh we lack a
little entrepreneurial Zing at the
moment and that's that's not as it
should be and so I I I didn't get in the
most important message what's my call my
main name is my main name is I got about
10 15 years ago very heavily in the
agriculture the de I got into it the
more I could see this chemical jungle
you know with all the pesticide and all
the fungicide so 95% of the food eaten
comes from industrial Farms on
Industrial Farms is see no more Fly Away
there's no more pheasants there's no
more Rapids we spray everything with
Fungicide and pesticides it gets in the
air we breat it gets in water we drink
it gets in the soil we eat the food and
all the kids practice Val cheese and
Stage to diabetics ear on the rise so my
main aim is my main goal is I don't
every I don't want to see any Canadian
kid to go to school hungry that means
breakfast got to be served I don't want
to see any Canadian kid to leave this
girl hungry that means lunch has got to
be served and by law it would the state
it has to be organic I got every
reasonable everything in but there's
lots more do where the public should
know thank you I enjoyed being with you
my pleasure man and uh we'll we'll meet
in a couple of minutes on the daily wire
side and then again in the future and
thanks again everybody for for watching
and listening
today
[Music]